hi I'm Ken raw the Executive Director of
Human Rights Watch one thing that
strikes me here in Davos is how the
discussion of economics is at such an
acro level that there's almost no
discussion of politics so maybe one way
to some that off with me the standards
and poor actually downgraded Egypt in
the course of this conference on even
though the developments in Egypt are
probably the best thing that could have
happened for the long-term economy in
the region that is to say the brittle
dictatorships of the Middle East have
stymied the innovation as needed for
economic growth what you see in the
uprising of Tunisia Egypt regardless of
how they come out represent an
aspiration of the people of that region
for much freer Society um that should be
something that's being plotted here but
instead of something that is just looked
at us as as a problem of short-term
instability that really highlights the
need for the discussions here in Davos
to be much better informed by the actual
aspirations of people around the world
rather than the more short-term needs of
our venture business community